les affaires sont bonnes pour Mohamed
ses clients si rien comme lui viennent
ici pour le réconfort des saveurs d'un
pays qu'ils ont quitté pour se réfugier
en Turquie mais récemment l'inquiétude
palpable donne un goût amer ou thé sucré
nous disons que si notre eau est coupé
on arrête de boire sans se plaindre nous
ne voulons pas nous mêler de la
politique du pays nous n'en avons pas le
droit
il ne parle pas le Turc mais il sait
bien que le sort des 3 millions 700 000
réfugiés syriens en Turquie est au cœur
de la campagne présidentielle
[Musique]
dans cette publicité de campagne le
candidat de l'opposition qui est
malkelich Daru dénonce la présence de 10
millions d'étrangers qu'il décrit comme
des machines à crimes en devenir qui
menacent la sécurité et l'économie du
pays
je ne veux pas que l'on sache que je
suis syrien dit Ibrahim dans la rue il
n'ose plus parler arabe il cherche à
tout prix à se faire discret
la guerre est presque finie consentille
mais ce n'est pas sécuritaire beaucoup
seraient forcé de faire leur service
militaire s'ils n'ont pas payé pour
l'éviter ce qu'ils l'ont fait ça va mais
on est nombreux à ne pas pouvoir partir
j'ai été en prison en Syrie avant de
venir ici ce serait un gros problème
pour moi
Ibrahim travaille comme vendeur de
séjour chirurgicaux touristiques
multilingue il peut ainsi trouver des
clients un peu partout dans le monde
pour ses patrons mais il s'est aussi
qu'il gagne moins cher qu'un employé
turc une tentation pour bon nombre
d'employeurs
ont besoin de travailler dit-il alors on
travaille pour moins d'argent on fait de
plus longues heures sans avoir les
permis légaux c'est ce qui fait que
certains Turcs ne nous aiment pas ils
disent que nous volons leur travail
la pression populaire pour le renvoi des
réfugiés de la Turquie force aussi
rejets à faire des concessions en
campagne il fait valoir que déjà 550 000
Syriens son retournés volontairement en
Turquie et il promet de renvoyer un
million plus rapidement le président que
le retour des Syriens chez eux va se
poursuivre sur une base volontaire
uniquement ce qui vient sur les Syriens
installés en Turquie mais parallèlement
rejeta hyper douane tant la main au
président Bachar al-Assad un homme qui
devait à tout prix partir disait-il
rapprochement qui inquiète
vaut mieux ne rien dire dit Mahmoud ça
me laisse 100 mots ça m'a choqué et pas
que moi ça me blesse droite au cœur
s'il parle aussi de mettre les réfugiés
syriens sur le chemin du retour le
président erdan souhaite au moins le
faire dans le respect et la dignité se
console Mahmoud après tout c'est lui qui
leur a ouvert les portes de la Turquie
comme on accueille un frère
je suis désolé de ramener la religion
dit-il mais ce sont les gens religieux
qui croient toujours que cet air est ici
pour tous les croyants vous venez ici je
suis musulman vous êtes musulman nous
sommes des frères
Mahmoud lui pourra voter dimanche le
professeur d'anglais fait partie des 220
000 personnes d'origine syrienne avoir
été naturalisée par la Turquie malgré sa
déception son choix en faveur du
dirigeant islamo conservateur reste une
évidence ici Marie-Eve Bédard
Radio-Canada
Istanbul